carlos hernandez
who is coming off of 11 days rest
and he got him with a fastball riding
away at 99 miles an hour
already first batter of the game look at
that that's a high riding action right
there at 99 and if mullins can't hit it
nobody can now trey mancini 2-2 pitch
swinging a miss got him with a fastball
that ends the inning two strikeouts in a
fly ball and down go the birds one two
three half an inning baltimore nothing
royals coming up whitmerfield is
in there for his 399th
consecutive game there's the veteran
matt harvey making his 19th start of the
year he's allowed 12 home runs so far
this year matt harvey trying to find his
way back to what he did in april and may
a ground ball to start from merritt
field and domingo leyba hoses him out
so one pitch one out for harvey to get
the all-star field and we mentioned he's
coming off 11 days rest
so i bet his arm feels great
and there's a breaking ball
and hernandez has struck out three of
the first four orioles owen won the
count pitch
and there's a dribbler to the left of
the mound charging lopez bare-handed
pick off balance throw to first won't
get erased
and so ramona reyes an infield single
the first hit by either team so far and
put two on with one out
and a fastball strikes out mckenna
and hernandez has struck out four
but today the fastball has been good the
location's down and you can see austin
wins patting the ground right there he
wants it down and that's a really good
pitch
so command is good and this is a slider
kind of we were talking about here
the one that gets it has a little bit of
depth to it it actually goes down you
see that ball going almost straight down
and that's the good one that's the
slider that we saw in april his first
seven starts the year at end of may
where he was really good and for me that
slide has been kind of more horizontal
kind of going across kind of right to
left more than it's had some depth to it
hitting 180 with eight home runs
lined like a bullet into right field
dozier got a pitch away and
slammed it hard into right and the
royals have their first base runner he's
ready again hernandez delivers hey
swings and this one finds the gap on the
left side for a base hit wins will hold
up at second and a single for austin
hayes he wins out the battle and there's
runners aboard first and second for the
o's marias has been really hot runners
in scoring position this year over 360.
bases chock full of birds
and goes after the first pitch and hits
it fair to right field this is going to
score multiple runs
wins and hayes stewart will stop at
third and make it a two-run double and
another two-hit game for ramon urrias
a lucrative third inning yet again for
the orioles who take the first lead on
sunday
ninth multi-hit game since taking over
at first base started out with a 4-2-6
pitch home
lopez did he go yes harvey comes inside
gets him on a breaking ball
lopez can't hold there's two outs with a
strikeout
three and two and the pitch and a swing
and a miss at a fastball up
and that's a strikeout of ryan mckenna
second time he has struck out today that
is striker number five on the day
for the royal starter today carlos
hernandez two and two in the pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a fastball at 97 so back-to-back
strikeouts so here's austin wins who's
their backup catcher walked on four
pitches leading off the third inning and
there's a line drive to left field over
has been attendee diving and he made the
catch he laid out and made a great
diving catch in left field for the final
out of the inning what a catch by andrew
benintendi diving to his right over
toward the left field line what a play
by benny to end the inning and a one two
three fourth i think their pitch is
efficient get right after guys and no
more free passes and they've done good
so far early make that play taylor dives
and makes the play against mullins
kyle zimmer says thank you very much
michael a taylor one down and you can
see how that ball was moving away from
him he timed that perfectly just like
ben and tindy so far
two outstanding diving catches by our
outfielders
continuing to save pitches even count
against austin hayes
now hit safely in 14 of his last 18
games batting over 300 during that
stretch
hayes hits it on a line out to left this
one is down ben and tendy backhands
hayes digging for two throw comes in it
is offline and austin hayes has himself
a one out double 99 miles an hour and he
gets to a breaking ball here and how
about that swing nice balanced own time
ben attendee has to go to the left
center field gap and austin hayes never
checked up and easily
makes it into second base trey has flied
out to right and he's also struck out in
this game
with a runner at second base in one out
that is a well struck ball into center
field from trey
and the oriole rbi leader adds another
a double from hayes a run scoring single
from mancini and it's three zip
one ball and two strikes against ryan
mckenna
breaking ball sprayed in a right field
base hit so he made one good pitch on a
curve ball earlier in the at-bat that
was a hanger it stayed in the middle and
mckenna hits it to the opposite field
for austin wins he's done a solid job
behind the plate since coming up
3-1 pits turned to left ben intended
he's not going to rob this one
andrew will get it at the foul line
mckenna
off on the crack of the bat is coming
around third he is safe
ryan mckenna all the way from first to
score
on a double from wins
speed kills in the orioles lead by four
that plays perfectly down the line
austin wins knows it's going to be a
fair ball ben attending gets to it as
fast as he can but ryan mckenna never
checked up all the way around from first
base here's a relay thrown i mean head
first and just by a fingernail he gets
in there and touches the back part of
the plate against domingo laba he's
reached base once on a hit by pitch
that's well struck by laban to right
field this will get down and bounce over
the wall in a hop so that'll be a double
for domingo laba
to lead off in the eighth he got
gutierrez coming up due for a hit basing
his former club nobody out eighth inning
the high hold one two pitch ground ball
to third eats up dozier plays it behind
third throw to first gutierrez is safe
down comes laba orioles take a
five-nothing lead and the royals defense
has been
not so good in this eighth inning dylan
trying to seal the victory
a ground ball to second base and the
orioles have a serious win to start the
second half
punctuated with a shutout in kansas city
matt harvey with perhaps his
finest hour
in oriole orange six scoreless innings
against his 2020 team
and brandon hyde is a really happy man
after a really tough friday night a 9-2
loss the orioles win it 8-4 on saturday
and 5-0 today
to claim the series victory over kansas
city